joe biden and russian president vladimir
putin met yesterday
in geneva for their first sit down since
joe took office
and after years of democrats attacking
president trump for allegedly going too
easy on russia
joe biden really let putin have a piece
of his mind yeah
that's right no more mr nice guy joe had
a clear message for putin
if you're going to attack our critical
infrastructure
you better make sure you only attack
some of it another
area we spent a great deal of time on
was cyber
and cyber security i talked about the
proposition that certain critical
infrastructure should be off
limits to attack period by cyber or any
other means i gave them a list
if i'm not mistaken i don't have it in
front of me 16
specific entities 16 defined
as critical infrastructure under u.s
policy
yeah number 17 you can blow that thing
to smithereens
but those 16 no way joe actually went
harder at a cnn reporter during this
trip than he did at putin
because according to our prevailing
culture the us congress the social media
victoria's secret
it's victoria's secret the real threats
we face don't come from our adversaries
abroad
they come from racism sexism
and fat phobia i'm michael knowles this
is the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from trucker pete
who says give nothing to the left
it'll never be enough very important
message it seems simple but somehow
people don't get it
this this has to do with juneteenth this
has to do with margaery taylor green
this has to do with an eternal political
maxim do not give anything
to the left they will not give you
credit they will
take more and more and more and
that leads to social chaos leads to
economic craziness and when that happens
you're going to want to make sure you
have
acre gold so you know that the price of
gold has been all over the place lately
now there is a new way to buy gold
through a company called
acre acre lets you subscribe to gold
bars for as little as
30 dollars a month michael you liar
you're probably thinking that right
michael you liar gold bars cost more
than 30
i know can you hear me out please thank
you acre has figured out this ingenious
method
whereby you pay 30 a month when your
gold stash reaches the price of their
gold bars
they will discreetly ship acre gold to
your house just recently
acre has introduced a new 100 a month
subscription to a 5 gram gold bar
acre lets you invest in physical gold
without coming out of pocket all at once
keeps you updated on your gold stash
every month and then you will discreetly
get
that acre gold shipped to your door it's
a really great hedge on
on inflation which is something we're
all worrying about right now
visit getacregal.com investing in
physical gold today make sure you go to
that url because acre's giving away a
gold bar
to qualify for the giveaway tweet or
post why you should be the recipient
and mention at get underscore acre that
is getacregold.com
knowles thank you aker gold for
supporting the show tough words from joe
biden
listen vlad listen vlad
please please only attack these 16 oh
please
do not attack these 16 things i'm sorry
it's confusing
because when you tell our adversary that
these 16 things would be the absolute
worst things to attack
please don't do it what you are in
effect telling him
is these are the 16 things you should
focus on attacking the irony of course
is that
donald trump was tougher on russia than
any president
since at least ronald reagan and maybe
going back even further there's no
question about it he was much tougher
than
obama or bush for that matter
or clinton or bush ii and i guess reagan
would
you know reagan did destroy the soviet
union so that would be
the most recent one but trump was very
very tough
and what does joe biden do when he comes
into office
he starts removing some of those
those sanctions some of those attacks
he's
he's giving putin what he wants
in certain areas of commerce and oil and
now he's saying you can attack us and it
won't won't really matter
don't don't attack those 16 things this
is
not just showing you the
u.s and russian relations under the
different parties it also shows you how
the left negotiates
when they're negotiating on behalf of
the country they negotiate from weakness
and this is the phrase of ronald reagan
peace through strength this is not a new
concept but the left
is always always arguing from a position
of weakness
abroad when they're talking about the
american nation this was a bad trip
overall for joe biden it was a he just
was testy he was tired he was
weak joe biden actually was tougher on a
cnn reporter a cnn reporter who
once a year a cnn reporter asks a
sort of almost fair question of the
president of the democrat president and
he can't take that they all have to be
softballs they all have to be what kind
of ice cream are you eating joe the
minute he gets a tough question
he snaps he went tougher on her than he
did on putin
i am not going to walk away why are you
so confident he'll change his behavior
mr president
yeah what are you doing
so when did i say i was confident
i said what will change their behavior
is that the rest of the world reacts to
them and it diminishes
their standing in the world i'm not
confident of anything
i'm just stating the fact but given his
past behavior has not changed and in
that press conference after sitting down
with you
for several hours he denied any
involvement in cyber attacks
he downplayed human rights abuses he
even refused to say
alexei navoni's name so how does that
account to a
constructive meeting as president
president putin you don't understand
that you're in your own business
quickly let's go quickly so this is
as tough on a journalist as donald trump
ever was and yet of course the coverage
you can actually see the coverage from
from some of the blue check journals on
twitter
they'll say donald trump refused to
answer a question and
stormed away this is an attack on our
democracy and then you see joe biden
well maybe she shouldn't have asked joe
biden that question and well you know
maybe this and that
he biden i think did actually have to
apologize for this because he had no
answer to the question
uh the question was a smart one and it
was an important one
there's no reason to believe that putin
is going to make good on his promises
joe biden has no leverage here and his
negotiation
was brutal it was awful it was it was
weak
cnn cnn has this one journalist caitlyn
collins who asks him a question
joe biden was not used to that because
joe biden
as he has told us already does not
want to get unexpected questions he gets
a list from his people
of the reporters that he is to call on
and when he loses his spot in the list
he actually holds up the press
conference and says
hold on a second here i've gotta i gotta
get out my paper to know which
pre-screened journalists
i'm allowed to talk to i'll take your
questions and as usual folks they gave
me a list
of the people i'm going to call on so uh
jonathan associated press
it's you're not supposed to say that
part joe that's
you just have it on the sheet and then
you pretend like you're you're just
calling on them
but you're not supposed to mention that
they gave you the list who is they
they are the people who are actually
running the country because it's
quite clear at this point that joe biden
is not do you feel comfortable with this
guy negotiating
on behalf of you and on behalf of your
communities in your country of course
not
but i suppose it doesn't really matter
because joe biden is just a stand-in for
the liberal blob and the liberal
establishment now
cnn does not have the only journalists
out there who very rarely but
on occasion switch up the narrative
we saw this the other night with no less
a liberal than
jon stewart jon stewart went on stephen
colbert's
cbs show these guys used to work
together on comedy central at the daily
show the colbert report
now they're coming and they actually
disagreed these are both
died in the wool liberals they disagreed
because jon stewart said you know
it sure does look like the virus came
from that lab in wuhan
i think we owe a great debt of gratitude
to science science has in many ways
helped
ease uh the suffering of this
pandemic which was
more than likely caused by science what
do you mean by do you mean like this
perhaps there's there's a chance that
this was created in a lab there's an
investigation
a chance well i don't i i i i oh my god
evidence i'd love to hear that there's a
novel respiratory coronavirus
overtaking wuhan china what do we do
oh you know who we could ask the wuhan
novel
respiratory coronavirus lab the disease
is the same name as the lab
think about stuart stewart actually is
pretty funny
right and he is a i don't think he's a
sophisticated political thinker
but he he points out what we have all
known for a year and a half
and this is where i want you to be very
careful do not give jon stewart credit
do not do it this is an op
this is fake do not believe this the
the purpose of this debate between jon
stewart and stephen
colbert and i'm not saying this is the
purpose that was going on in jon
stewart's mind or stephen colbert's mind
i'm saying this is the reason this is
being
blown up and being talked about right
now is to create the
illusion that that parts of the media
are
reasonable on this parts of the media
are losing their using their common
sense
where was jon stewart a year and a half
ago where was he
where were the mainstream media a year
and a half ago he's right
yeah oh the novel coronavirus that was
found in bats
is uh discovered right next to the novel
coronavirus in bats laboratory in wuhan
oh wow what a coincidence when we said
that a year and a half ago
the john stewarts of the world were
either silent
or were telling us that we were crazy
coup conspiracists
and big technology companies were
censoring us
and were fact-checking us and were
telling us that that was absolutely
crazy and unscientific
and we should be ostracized from society
and now they're saying well what i mean
obviously we've got common sense
obviously it had something to do with
the lab
yes that's true i'm glad that you agree
with me johnny come lately
but it's so disingenuous because you had
to cover it up a year and a half ago
because it contradicted your political
agenda and it would have put into
greater peril the 2020 election that you
were trying to win and it would have
given donald trump credit for being
obviously correct
at the time that they all said no he's a
racist he's unscientific he's a ruby's
an idiot
trump god i want to say
97 out of 100 things right
on the coronavirus the mainstream media
and the dr faucis and the democratic
party
got i was going to say 3 out of 100
things right i think it's 0 out of 100
things right on the coronavirus
and now they're going to try to come in
and pretend
that they were reasonable on this as
well no thank you sorry
it's not going to work i'm glad that jon
stewart is learning and he's coming back
around
and he's going to try to do better
that's fine we'll give him grace to do
that in the future
but a year and a half late ain't going
to cut it no do not
fall for this they were entirely wrong
on the virus they have new credibility
they should not be believed on any part
of it
from now on and you're going to hear a
whole lot about not just the vaccines
the vaccine passports the new
the new lockdowns for the new variants
or whatever don't believe them don't
believe them about any of it
if they hadn't squandered their
credibility day in
and day out by the by the hour by the
minute for a year and a half then maybe
they
they could be believed but as of now
they cannot you've got to be prepared
for stuff folks
got to be prepared which is why i
strongly recommend you check out trust
and will
at trustanwill.com setting up an estate
plan is simple
it's convenient it's secure for as
little as 39. you can nominate guardians
for your children
determine who gets your stuff and plan
for future medical care
all from the comfort of your home trust
and will documents are designed by
estate planning experts
and customized for the state you live in
with live customer support seven days a
week
trustandwill.com's team is available to
answer any questions you have
while setting up your plan trust in will
is a trusted name
in online estate planning the category
leader on trustpilot
and they've helped hundreds of thousands
of people protect their families
assets and legacy i have had a will
since i was a very young man since i was
a teenager it's very important
to up to make sure it's up to date
especially if you have a little kid
especially if you buy a house or
something like that just get peace of
mind seriously get peace of mind right
now at trustandwill.com
slash knowles get 10 off plus free
shipping of your customized
legal documents don't wait go right now
very very important 10
off plus free shipping at
trustingwill.com knowles trust in
will.com
knowles there will be no accountability
from the mainstream media they lie and
they lie and they spread fake news and
that's
always true but i'm i'm talking about
something much more egregious than
fibbing about some politician or
whatever
they were complicit in
shutting down the country for a year and
a half
and now they're going to change their
tune that the fact of the matter is
undeniable
with regard to china's complicity with
regard to the wuhan laboratory with
regard to
the very likely human role in developing
this virus
now they're going to try to change their
tune don't let them do it
there's never any accountability from
these guys on a totally separate issue
i have to play you i meant to play it
for you a few days ago but
it's still quite relevant anna navarro
who is a fake republican she's one of
the republicans
one of the court jester conservatives
who is
hired by the leftist media to dance
around and do a little soft shoe and put
a jester hat on
and pretend to be a republican to give
the illusion
of debate and her entire purpose is to
prop
up the ruling liberal regime but
if the ruling liberal regime only had
liberals on the shows
only had open liberals on the shows then
it would seem
like north korea or something it would
seem like
assad syria or putin's russia it would
seem like there's no
dissent whatsoever but if they put on
some fake republicans who you know they
put on their republican makeup and they
do a little dance
then it at least gives the illusion of
debate so anna navarro is one of these
people on
on the view on abc anna navarro came out
defending another journalist mainstream
media star who's not going to have any
accountability
jeffrey toobin jeffrey duman who was
caught in the words of woody allen
having sex with someone he loves
on a zoom call on for the new yorker
magazine he's now being rehabilitated
there's no problem at all
for jeffrey toobin so he he
is coming back into the mainstream and
he's he's uh you know going to
be on cnn again and anna navarro says
you know what
i think it's perfectly fine you know
actually i'm not surprised he's back on
the air but i will tell you when i saw
that interview
oh god how embarrassing how humiliating
i
i kept thinking to myself if i have to
go
on live tv and explain to the nation why
i masturbated on assume call i think i'd
rather go sell avocados under i-95
than get my job back on tv look um
i think some instances of sexual
harassment
are black and white some instances are
uh
more nuanced in this case uh he was not
sexually harassing
anybody he didn't have the intent to
sexually harass somebody he was sexually
harassing himself
uh maybe okay he was on a zoom call he
was it was an accidental
exposure it was not a cnn zoom call it
was with the new yorker from where
he has been terminated and faced
consequences
anna navarro's commentary here is
accidentally interesting
i don't think she knows why it's
interesting
but it is for her and don't forget she's
considered to be
one of the conservative people on the
view she isn't she's a
died in the wool liberal but for her
the only fault that one can
can engage in is the violation of
consent
the only criterion that matters when
we're making moral judgments
for anna navarro is consent
right it's the harassment it's in
infringing
on someone else's desires or feeling of
comfort
and so he jeffrey toobin did that he
just didn't know that he did that he
said it was a sort of accidental
exposure an accidental sexual harassment
but to me the
sexual harassment was not really so much
the issue
like yes i mean i'm sure people felt
uncomfortable looking at that on zoom
and that was i'm sure
terribly unpleasant for them but it was
the behavior itself
it was shameful for him why why is it
shameful
why is it shameful and and embarrassing
and why would anna navarro rather go
sell avocados underneath a bridge than
have to show her face on television
again if she got caught doing that
because the act is shameful itself to
quote norm mcdonald
sex is a filthy shameful thing that is
obviously only meant for procreation he
put
for that one of his comedy albums and
norm mcdonald's one of the greatest
political philosophers around
jeffrey tubin did a thing that we just
know intrinsically
is shameful and that brings us
embarrassment
and that's why anna navarro would rather
go sell the avocados underneath the
bridge
but she doesn't understand that we don't
have the moral language to talk about
private acts as though they can be right
or wrong but
now on the left and even in part on the
right anything that you want to do
so long as it is in private and doesn't
hurt someone else
in in some obvious way is considered to
be a-okay
that's a very degraded shallow moral
vision of politics
and it's why all of even the people who
are conservatives today actually seem a
lot
like liberals you just think about this
phrase you ever hear
hey don't be a wanker i guess it's said
more in the united kingdom than here hey
don't be
why why don't you want to do it because
there's something
shameful about that and we can transform
society
and deconstruct and you know
contrive this and that but it doesn't
that's always going to be
the case speaking of guys looking at
pictures of hot women and speaking of
human nature
not changing victoria's secret
is getting rid of the angels victoria's
secret is getting rid of all the hot
chicks
and they're making a conscious decision
to trade the hot chicks
for megan repino that radical
purple-haired lesbian soccer player
and they're going to do this as a major
massive marketing turnaround to give
women what they really
want so this is the headline new york
times victoria's secret swaps angels for
what women want will they buy it this
shows you
speaking of self-love and self-obsession
this shows you how mistaken this modern
ideology is
the embattled lingerie giant is
attempting the most extreme brand
turnaround in recent memory an effort to
redefine
not just itself but also the very idea
of what sexy is
so so what i'm trying to be like polite
about this
victoria's secret is now going to say
that
what was that woman's name tara banks
you know she was like extremely
attractive
or all of the victoria's secret angels
they are no longer set they're going to
redefine sexy
so they are no longer sexy sexy is
megan repino sexy is
people who are not sexy
that's that's the that's the argument
even that the new york times is making
okay this is i guess just one of the
most
ridiculous examples of how the left
tries to redefine the words in order to
redefine reality you might say they try
to
control words to control minds which is
the subject of my upcoming book
speechless
available now for period just in case i
didn't know if the bill was going to
come in on time
just in case you can get that right now
that speechless i think is only oh my
gosh
oh my god it's only available for
pre-order for another five days folks
you can get a signed first edition copy
from premiere collectibles
for five more days then it will no
longer be on pre-order
it will be on order but they will not be
on pre-order anymore so go get
speechless today you go to you can go to
you can go to speechlessbook.com i'm
going to double up on the pavlovian
responses
so that that's their plan they're going
to at victoria's secret get rid of the
hot angels and put in these people who
are not
not attractive they say this is what
women want
why do women buy victoria's secret do
they buy victoria's secret
just for themselves no
they buy victoria's secret for me
and for you other guy listening to this
show and for you
guy listening to this show in your car
they buy
victoria's secret to make themselves
attractive
to men there may be some other reasons
maybe it feels more comfortable
in certain ways but really that's not it
the purpose of victoria's secret
is to be sexy right that's what new york
times is telling you they're redefining
what sexy is
it's to be sexy who are they sexy for
they're sexy for men
i know that today we're supposed to
pretend that 90
of the population are like trans bi
non-binary lesbian what but that's just
not true
the overwhelming majority of people 97
or so are basically ordinary in their
sexual views
and for the vast vast vast majority of
women they're trying to attract men
and men are not attracted
how do i i don't want to be rude to
anybody men are attracted to people who
are sexy and what is sexy
is to to a very small degree socially
constructed
and to the much larger degree natural it
comes from our loins it comes from our
dna
it comes from our caveman brain and no
amount of social engineering is going to
change that
this victoria's secret story is the
whole story of progressive politics
they the progressive looks at the world
and says i hate this world i hate the
way society is i hate the way we live i
hate nature itself
and i'm just gonna change it and i can
change that through my unfettered reason
and through my tyranny of will in
politics which can
turn the world into anything that i want
it to be ye shall be as gods
as the serpent tells eve in the garden
of eden
as whitaker chambers the ex-communist
describes communism as saying
it's it's the serpent in the garden you
shall be his gods but you shan't be you
really will not be
you can't totally change the world the
experiments in politics fail and i
strongly suspect the experiment from
victoria's secret
is going to fail too you know
there are great books to pre-order these
days notably
speechless controlling words controlling
minds it's hard to get the three at once
uh uh the second best book you can
pre-order right now the authoritarian
moment by bench bureau it's available
for pre-order at amazon barnes and noble
or any other major bookseller and it
will be my campaign slogan someday
if you go to the amazon prime video page
by the way you'll find an entire section
dedicated to black voices
black this is the most there's black
voices from black
history month or black lives matter
month or i don't know
now once upon a time you were also able
to find
created equal clarence thomas's
documentary that details his rise
from the segregated south of the highest
court in the land
and the all-out war that was waged on
him by the left during his confirmation
process which by the way is
an episode that i talk about my upcoming
speechless controlling words controlling
minds
[Music]
however even though clarence thomas is
one of the most important black voices
in the country
the documentary just mysteriously
disappeared from amazon's queue
during none other than that sacred black
history month
it's not you can't get it anywhere
that's so strange take a quick look at
the trailer
i was never going to be white the
problem is i could never go back
completely to the world i came from
[Music]
i saw what i had become and then i asked
god and if you take
anger out of my heart i'll never hate
again you're not really black because
you're not doing what we expect black
people to do
that's when all heck broke loose so
you'd still like to serve on the supreme
court
i'd rather die than withdraw from the
process
[Music]
man clarence thomas just just loved that
guy so you can stream create it equal
tomorrow
live at 9 00 pm eastern 8 pm central not
on those big tech platforms
at dailywire.com if you're not yet a
daily wire member join with code justice
for 20 off your membership and get this
clarence thomas documentary and all our
other great content
like our talk show candace our first
film run hide fight and whole lots of
other stuff
on demand we'll be right back with a lot
more
victoria's secret is trading in the
angels
for megan repino they're trading in
people traditionally considered to be
sexy for according to the new york times
people who are
not they are doing that because
the very idea of making oneself
desirable to another person
is now considered wrong unjust
and bigoted you've seen a lot of tick
talks going around
tick tock i guess i actually i'm not on
tiktok because i don't want to give xi
jinping all of my data
but you do see these videos going around
youtube are going around twitter
from tiktok and a woman explained
the even even murkier more bigoted
orange in the origins of fat phobia it
doesn't just come
from anti-fatness it also comes from
racism here's your reminder that fat
phobia is rooted in racism
as always if you haven't read this book
go do that
the main thing to understand is that for
the last 300-ish years
white folks have been marketing fatness
as a black trait
and this is regardless of whether or not
black people individually were actually
fat
that was irrelevant the message they
spread was that black women specifically
were ravenous and uncontrollable
and these barbaric traits made them fat
on the flip side
thinness was marketed as a white trait
again regardless of whether or not
individual white people were actually
thin
that was irrelevant the idea was that
white women specifically were refined
and restrained
and this led them to having delicate
thin bodies over the years these
messages have become more subtle but
even today they are still very prevalent
in conversations around race health
capitalism and poverty
so so fat phobia is the
well i guess literally it would mean the
irrational fear of fat people but that's
not what we're talking about here
what she means fat phobia she means
having a preference
specifically a sexual preference for
people that you find more attractive
than other people
and if you have that if you have just a
natural attraction that's bigoted
that's racist and she's saying that fat
phobia
the by which she means just being
attracted to people you're attracted to
that is rooted in racism because
terrible white people all those white
people
marketed the idea that black women were
fat regardless of the individual black
women now
do you notice the logical error there
she's saying it's terrible to generalize
about black women
which is what although all those white
people did well aren't you generalizing
about the white people
you're you're willing to get specific
and individual about the black people
but not about the white people because
there's a complete
double standard because this argument is
incoherent but it's just designed
to get at a deep racial animus and she
says this is was awful
let's assume that her premise is true
that in popular culture black women were
considered to be on average more likely
to be fat
that's just true that's that's true
that's actually one of the reasons
that the coronavirus was tougher in
black communities than
it was in white communities is because
in certain black communities they were
more likely to be obese and
obesity was a comorbidity obesity was
was considered
to be a factor that would put you at
greater risk so
yeah that that's true you're denying now
statistics the right facts that we can
see from the
cdc and from from other agencies
is that it's a hate fact you're not
allowed to acknowledge that
no because if you acknowledge that fact
then
you're perpetuating inequality well it
wouldn't it be better than
to just like try to solve the problem
well no if you try to solve the problem
and deal with these health issues in the
black community which we have been told
is
is very important part of inequality is
that there are worse health outcomes in
the black community
okay well then perhaps we should tell
people who are obese to lose weight well
you can't do that because that's fat
phobic well then what on earth are we
supposed to do
you're supposed to feel bad about
yourself and you're supposed to deny
your attractions and you're supposed to
hate your self and your ancestry
and you're supposed to upend nature
oh is that all okay that's fine that's
what that's ultimately what it comes
down to there can be
no solution to this there can be no
victory everything is about racism and
racism can never be solved
and when some racial issues seem more
important than others we always have to
redirect
as the attorney general merrick garland
just did and
explain away every problem in society by
white supremacy the number of open
fbi domestic terrorism investigations
this year
has increased significantly according to
an unclassified summary of the march
intelligence assessment
the two most lethal elements of the
domestic violence extremist threat
are racially or ethnically motivated
violent extremists
and militia violent extremists in the
fbi's view
the top domestic violent extremist
threat comes from
racially or ethnically motivated violent
extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority of the white race
according to the fbi the biggest threat
in the country
is white supremacists and that is just
obviously ridiculous it's
just oh my gosh
name the last
organized white supremacists talking
about militias and all these
organizations
name the last organized white
supremacist
terror attack and you name it what
what you're going to name if we're
trying to be as fair as possible to
these people
like merrick garland is you're going to
say the capital riot
okay who who did the racist white
supremacist i didn't see
very many of them but let's let's say
that's let's let's conflate everything
let's say that every trump supporter is
an evil vicious white supremacist
neo-nazi
obviously not true but let's say it who
did
that that group of people kill at the
capitol riot
officer brian sicknick nope that's not
true even the new york times had to
admit that was a lie
uh some other nope nope nobody nobody
the only person who was killed in the
violence of that day
was one of the trump supporters ashley
babbitt killed by
ostensibly by a capitol hill police
officer but they're all really mum about
it no one is
is talking about it no
no transparency whatsoever okay
now what about in the summer of 2020
when when was the last
black racially motivated mob uh
tearing up major cities oh for all of
2020 right
the the organization was called black
lives matter wasn't exclusively black
people
there were there were also some antifa
people there as well that would
smash in windows but that obviously was
a
a racial movement it was not a not a
white supremacist movement
and they burned down minneapolis burned
down los angeles burned down
washington dc burned down san francisco
burned on and burned down chicago on
and on and on and merrick garland stands
up there with a straight face and says
well the really the big threat is white
supremacist how many how many
people are members of the ku klux klan
anymore i i suspect
virtually every card carrying member of
the ku klux klan
is just an fbi informant right they're
all it's just the fbi
sort of spying on other people working
for the fbi
but but it's white supremacy it's the
biggest problem in the whole wide world
and so we need to pass a new holiday
specifically
to recognize the evils the white
supremacist evils of this country
and how we've overcome them in that
holidays juneteenth
juneteenth the most sacred day we talked
about it a little yesterday but there's
a new of it so the senate passed it
a couple days ago then the house passed
it yesterday it's going to the
president's desk
everyone is in support of juneteenth
everybody
it was unanimous in the senate there
were a handful of republicans in the
house who opposed it
virtually every conservative commentator
is trying to come out on the side of
this being a really good idea because
they don't want to be called racists
i'm going to level with you i'm just
going to shoot straight it's a bad idea
juneteenth should not be a federal
holiday it shouldn't
it's it's purely a leftist
contrivance as it currently stands and
no republican should go along with it
there were 10 federal holidays each year
do you know what those federal holidays
are
new year's day independence day
thanksgiving day christmas day
washington's birthday memorial day labor
day veterans day columbus day
love that one and the birthday of martin
luther king jr
this holiday this 11th annual holiday
juneteenth
seems categorically different to me than
these
other holidays and i was trying to put
my finger on it i said what is it what
is it about
juneteenth that is different than these
other holidays and i realized
all of these other holidays involve
gratitude they're essentially about
gratitude
thanksgiving obviously you give thanks
to god christmas day obviously you give
thanks to god
independence day even you give thanks to
god john adams said this that the day
should be filled with
pious devotions to to god for delivering
us and giving us our freedom our
independence
even new year's day new year's day you
give thanks to one another for old lang
zine
uh washington's birthday columbus day
and martin luther king jr day
are to give thanks to these great men
who have
accomplished great things in the country
memorial day actually was begun as a
civil war holiday after lincoln was
assassinated to
to memorialize the civil war dead who
gave their lives for the very purpose of
freeing the slaves
labor day to give thanks to the ordinary
americans who keep the country going
veterans day obviously to give thanks to
the veterans what does juneteenth
give thanks for it's not
emancipation proclamation day all right
that would that would be just a lincoln
day basically thanks lincoln for freeing
the slaves
it's not 13th amendment ratification day
thanks
legislators for outlawing slavery in the
country
juneteenth is just this day when a union
general makes it to galveston texas
and tells people that the slaves had
been freed three years prior by abraham
lincoln
it's just a local celebration in
galveston until a few years ago when
political activists decided to try to
make it the most sacred day on the
calendar
but why why juneteenth i suspect the
reason that they prefer juneteenth to
say
emancipation proclamation day is because
it is now very unfashionable
on the left to give credit to abraham
lincoln for freeing the slaves there was
a piece
came out in the atlantic magazine one of
the editors there a few years ago some
years ago more than that
invading against a bunch of movies 12
years a slave
a number of other movies and including
lincoln
for perpetuating what they called white
savior narratives they said this is
awful you can't we should not have
movies where white people do good things
to black people
or for black people we can't do that he
said what lincoln
link abraham lincoln the white savior
who freed the slaves he's not you can't
have a white savior narrative in that
movie no
he didn't free the slaves they freed
themselves that's not true but that's
what they're saying
just the other day you saw this this npr
tv critic
attacking tom hanks and saying that tom
hanks has spent
much of his career in his historical
movies portraying white people
white men doing the right thing and
that's unacceptable white men cannot do
the right thing
so i suspect the reason that it's not
emancipation proclamation day
is because that would have to give
credit to abraham lincoln a white guy
and you can't you can't do that
i suspect the reason it's not 13th
amendment ratification is you have to
give credit to
a lot of white guys you're not allowed
to do that that would be a white savior
narrative
i suspect that the reason that
juneteenth has been selected
is because it's just this kind of
inconclusive moment
on the way in between the emancipation
proclamation and the 13th amendment
that is just kind of giving some news
but it's unfinished
it's not a holiday about gratitude it's
about resentment you don't need to take
my word for it
this is the this is what rashida talib
said during the debate this national
holiday will serve as a powerful
reminder that we cannot run from our
past
not thank you for freeing the slaves no
no it's we cannot run from our vicious
past
uh who's this other woman brenda
lawrence democrat says during the debate
it's also a recognition that we have so
much work to do
to rid this country of systemic racism
discrimination and hate so much work to
do not
something was accomplished that would be
emancipation proclamation day or 13th
amendment day would be something was
accomplished let's give thanks for that
this is no no it wasn't accomplished so
much work to do
and then obama i think proved it last
year when he tweeted out
juneteenth has never been a celebration
of victory
or an acceptance of the way things are
it's a celebration of progress it's an
affirmation
that despite the most painful parts of
our history change is possible
and there is still so much work to do
this is it this is the perpetual
revolution that can never end
there's always so much nothing to be
grateful for the past
always evil the future always better we
need to overcome the evil past
to get into the glorious future it's a
progressive holiday
it is the holiday of progressivism and
by the way it's not the bill is not just
called the juneteenth bill
it's called the juneteenth national
independence day bill
it is a reframing of our very
independence day away from july 4th
1776. that was a bad day when bad evil
white men
cynically pretended to be calling for
independence but really they weren't
they were just propertied white men
you know grounding our country founding
it in
in racism and bigotry that's the 1619
project says this
it's historically illiterate but what
she's saying is that the america was
founded to protect slavery completely
untrue but that's that's the argument
to reframe american history this holiday
is about reframing
american history it's about reframing
our independence day it's too bad the
republicans
went along with it most republicans went
along with it
now there is someone out there who wants
to break the mold
and run for president i'm not talking
about
the republicans not not talking about
ron desantis who's obviously running for
president i'm not talking about
some democrat kamala harris who may
already be the president we're not sure
i'm talking about a centrist who's voted
for both republicans and democrats
i'm talking about a man that 46 percent
of americans according to some probably
bogus poll
want to run for president i'm talking
about
dwayne the rock johnson do you smell how
the rock is campaigning
i do dwayne the rock johnson
i was just giving an interview to people
magazine who's referring to this poll
that 46
of americans want him to run for
president he said it's a humbling honor
and that he would consider it he said
he's going to go on a listening tour
and figure out if people really want him
to run and this is his argument
i love our country to my core and i'm
endlessly grateful for the opportunities
i've had here as a half black half
samoan kid
being able to work my ass off knowing
tenacity opens doors
in a lot of ways i'm indebted to our
great country for it
i am not eager for the rock presidency
okay i'm not eager for the rock
candidacy
i don't like that he endorsed uh
joe biden and kamala harris this last
time i don't think he knows a damn thing
about politics
i strongly suspect he would not be a
very good president
however i would take him
any day even this guy who i don't think
he knows very much about politics i
would take him
any day over joe biden
i would take him any day over i guess
anyone in the democratic party for for
this one reason
for by the way the rock's policies may
be further left than some of these
people
we just don't know right he's just an
entertainer but the rock
seems to like our country
isn't that a novel thing it's an it used
to be that both parties loved our
country waved the flag
but we had disagreements about certain
issues
today we are told by joe biden by the
current president
who's a thousand years old who's his
establishment as they get he says this
country was founded on the original sin
of white supremacy we've got to overcome
our past it's the same stuff here from
obama
it's the same stuff you hear in the in
the juneteenth bill arguments
that the country is a terrible place and
we've got to overcome it and dwayne the
rock johnson is
giving saying something it's so simple
but it's it's so nice
that he's grateful to the country that
it's a good place
he loves his country you should love
your country
love of country is an extension of love
of your parents it's an extension of
filial piety
even if you've got problems with your
country you should still have a love of
your country this is why this you know
sometimes you hear this dichotomy
my country right or wrong my country
only went right
this is not even a prescriptive question
it's just a descriptive one your country
is your country when it's right or wrong
and you need to stand by your country
and you need to have courage and you
need to try to fix the things
that ought to be fixed of course
and dwayne the rock johnson at least at
this very base level
very base level if you ask me
understands this kind
of gratitude we are not going to have a
country very long though
if we don't get certain things under
control namely
immigration what do we have something
like three
i'm sorry 6 000 people pouring across
our border every single
day now this is untenable the left loves
it because it's giving them future
voters
statistically overwhelmingly likely to
vote for democrats
either once they get amnesty or down the
road so greg abbott he's saying joe
biden's not going to give us
any money for the wall he's actually
halted construction of the wall so you
know what
we're going to build it ourselves in a
letter
greg abbott directed the executive
director of the texas department of
criminal justice to transfer a quarter
billion dollars in general revenue to
the disaster fund
within this trusted programs uh within
the office of the governor
this will be a down payment to begin
designing construction of the wall with
mexico
really good stuff because greg abbott
he's obviously throwing red meat out to
the conservatives and he's saying we're
going to build the wall ourselves
but that in a buck 50 i'll get you a cup
of coffee if you don't actually have the
fund so he's transferring a quarter
billion dollars to build it that's good
stuff
ron desantis not to be outdone governor
of florida
is saying that he is going to send
florida law enforcement personnel
to texas to protect the border today
we're here to announce that the state of
florida is
answering the call florida is going to
support texas and arizona
we believe that securing the southern
border is important for our country
but specifically we believe it will
benefit the people of florida
uh to be able to get this under control
and so where the federal government has
failed
the states are stepping up and doing our
best to fill the void
wow this is pretty big stuff this is
pretty big stuff
he is saying we're going to send florida
law enforcement to another state i is
the governor of florida i'm going to
send my law enforcement
to another state to
deal with the border this is a very
ambitious play
it's a very dangerous play if any
florida law enforcement officer is
killed or frankly even injured
down there at the border desantis is
going to have big trouble he's going to
be accused
of derelicting his duty of compromising
his responsibility to floridians
to because of his national ambitions
you're
saying there's no reason you should have
been sending those guys over to the
texas border now the way he could defend
it is to say look
we are a country all right we are
individual states but we are a country
together and the problem of illegal
immigration
is a problem that's going to affect
floridians too it's going to affect our
whole country even if not one single
illegal alien came to florida the
political issues caused by this will
affect florida
we are not just islands floating off by
ourselves we are together in a country
so it's an important matter for florida
to deal with this
it's a little bit of a tenuous argument
but he could do it
the fact is
if and when he runs for president this
is going to be a good line he's going to
be able to say look i
broke the mold i stood up in a way i
took on
national issues he's going to have a
record on one of the most important
issues
in the republican party this guy is
running
very very seriously for president
president this guy
is obviously very sharp he he sees what
he's doing and
he he is identifying you forget desantis
for a second he's identifying this
immigration issue
this issue of national identity this
issue of who we are and what kind of
political control
we are even allowed to have the the
bureaucracy and the liberal
establishment says we can't even control
who comes into the country
and he's saying yes we can he is betting
that that is going to be issue the issue
that motivates
republicans the left is betting that
racial division is going to be the issue
that motivates democrats and you're
going to i think both of them are right
i think you're going to see that duked
out what's the real threat where is the
real
america what is what is the sort of
issue that lies at the heart
the real heart of americans that's the
question for the next three years i'm
michael knowles the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 today on the
ben shapiro show president biden has his
showdown with vladimir putin and it
doesn't go great the federal reserve
dramatically increases its inflation
estimate and the left celebrates
juneteenth becoming a national holiday
by
calling america racist that's today on
the ben shapiro show give it a listen